[موسيقى]
هل تعلمون ان اغلى الاشبال في العالم
استخلصت من حليب الحمير ليس هذا فحسب بل
ان حليبها يستخدم في صناعه الصابون
والعديد من مستحضرات التجميل ايضا
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من عالم
غريب
[موسيقى]
ربما لم يتذوق احد منكم من قبل طعمه حليب
الحمير لكنه للمفاجاه غني بالفيتامينات
وبمغذيات تعمل على تقويه الجهاز المناعيه
حتى ان خبراء يقولون انه الاقرب لحليب
الامهات
ففي صربيا مثلا ما هو تحديدا في محميه غرب
العاصمه بلغراد توجد مزرعه فريده ربما لا
يوجد مثيل لها في العالم فهي متخصصه في
انتاج الاجباري من حليب الحمير تحلب
الاناث ثلاث مرات في اليوم في عمليه يجب
اجرائها يدويا
مجهود ضخم يبذل هنا المزارعون يحتاجون الى
نحو خمسه انواع 25 لترا من الحليب لانتاج
كيلو جرام واحد من الجبن لكن هذا المجهود
لا يضيعها اباءنا فسعر الكيلو الواحد قد
يصل الى خمسه الاف دولار
[موسيقى]
اما عن حليب الحمير فهو صحي جدا للبشر
هكذا ان يقول مختصون الذي يحتوي على
خصائصه مضاده للحساسيه كما ينبغي ان يشرب
طازجه لان مكوناته ثمينه تضيع في حاله
غليه فعلى سبيل المثال فيتامين سي موجود
في حليب الحمير بكميه اكبر ب 60 مره مقرره
بحليب الابقار في المانيا وفي ظل انتشار
وباقي كورونا استاد اعتقاد لدى البعض بان
حليب الحمير يحميه من الاصابه بالفيروس
وتزايد الطلب عليه رغم سعره المرتفع الذي
وصل الى 60 دولارا للتر الواحد
[موسيقى]
على الجيزه ابو تبرونشيتي
ومن المانيا الى الاردن فهذا المصنع مخصص
لانتاج الصابون ومستحضرات التجميل من حليب
الحمير الطازج
كل المكونات
تبعتنا طبيعيه 100% من ناحيه الزيوت
الطبيعيه اللي نشتريها من داخل البلد من
هنا صورته بتتكون من اااه زيت زيتون زيت
اللوز والزيت جوز الهند حليب الاتان يعني
ما في مواد اللي هي كيميكالز اللي ممكن
تؤثر بشكل او باخر على البشره
بالاضافه الى حليب الحمير فان مكونات
الصابون تحتوي على زيت الزيتون وزيت جوز
الهند وعناصر اخرى ويتم بيع القطعه
الواحده بنحوي عشره دولارات
[موسيقى]
في تجربته الجبن ام الحليب ام الصابون